we're gonna have the latest on the
morning for queen elizabeth of course as
the scene is about to shift from
scotland over to london people as you
might expect are still lining up to view
the queen's coffin in edinburgh before
it's taken to britain's capital city
tonight at one point king charles and
his brothers and his sister stood guard
around the coffin that fulfills a royal
tradition we're going to begin our
coverage with elizabeth palmer in
edinburgh with more on that elizabeth it
was a very touching scene to see all the
siblings surrounding their mother's
coffin yesterday
deeply touching very somber
that saint giles cathedral you can see
behind me that's where they were and
this morning
the queen's body is still there lying at
rest and we have not seen a single gap
in the
line of people filing in to say alas
goodbye
last night king charles his brothers the
princes andrew and edward and his sister
princess anne gathered around their
mother's remains and stood heads bowed
in a gesture at once ceremonial and
deeply personal
earlier in the day queen elizabeth's
body had left hollywood house her home
in edinburgh for the last time
silent crowds watched the hearse travel
through the heart of the city along the
historic royal mile
for the service of thanksgiving for
queen elizabeth's life the oldest crown
in the kingdom the crown of scotland was
laid on her coffin
outside scots and visitors from around
the world waited patiently to file
throughs and jouses to pay their
respects
four thousand people an hour were
expected to file past the coffin and
even so the lines stretched out of sight
really surreal and
more emotional than i could ever
remember it was actually one of the most
emotional moments of my life
night fell
and still they came determined to pay
tribute
we know it's real but when you see
a coughing in there it
comes home
it's very real very sad
king charles though officially in
mourning was also hard at work
monarch in waiting for so many years
this was the real thing
at hollywood house with his wife camilla
he accepted condolences from
well-wishers his new subjects
thank you so much
he also met scottish lawmakers
i had thoughts and
prayers
on on these these awful occasions which
we have to face
i know but you're you know you're
doodling with so many great personal
vlogs well
there we are it's called duty
duty once his mother's deepest
commitment will now rule the rest of
charles's life
now there are just a few hours left of
public viewing because the queen's
coffin
will be
loaded early this evening onto a royal
air force plane and taken to london
where the next chapter of this
extraordinary
ceremony will unfold nate
elizabeth palmer in scotland thank you